Chứ kinh trang loạn của giữa lộn về chất lần của điện về tâm gây đầu sau báo số người tại Hà Tính,
công ty định lực Hà Tính đã có thung tín phản hồi chính thức.
Theo đó,
Cô địa này thuộc giữa an đã vận hàng thứ 5 hàng yên thường trong mối bốn,
gió công ty chắc giềm hiệu hạn khánh vình sản xuất theo tuy chuẩn Việt Nam TCVN 5 tà 1 bài một chi chiến tờ,
sản phẩm đã được chung tâm trứng nhận của hợp quạch sét,
tâm trứng nhận chất lượng trước khi lắt đặt.
Giải phát hiện về kết tổ bên trong cột phía địa lực cho biết,
tư chuẩn hiện hàng không bắt bột chi giúp một loại khác,
nhà sản xuất có thể sự giúp các giản thép khác nhau,
miếng là đà bảo khả năng chìu lực theo đúng thiết gế đã được phí duyệt.
Hẹn tại, công ty định lực Hà Tính đã cù cấp phản bộ hồ xưa cho cửa quan tôn ăn,
nế phối hợp kiểm tra,
lồng thời yêu cầu nhà sản xuất giả xuất lại quy trình,
thiến nghiệm các chỉ tiêu kiếc thuận,
lần Việt khẳng định sẽ mưng bạc thông tin và sự liên nghiêm lếu phát hiện sản phẩm không đặt tiêu chuẩn.